[Laughter]
[Music]
hey Conan O'Brien here welcome to uh
installment four of the Lost Hans and
Franz movie The girlyman Dilemma
you've been following and I think you
have if you're listening to episode four
if not you're an idiot if you're
starting with this one it will make no
sense we are reading a script that was
written in 1991 by Dana Carvey Kevin
Neal and Robert Smigel myself featuring
what we hoped would be Arnold
Schwarzenegger in the starring role
we'll tell you if that ended up
happening or not don't Google it and so
now where things are really coming along
here I think when we when we last left I
believe Ralph who's evil evil Ralph was
sucking the flab from film critic Jesus
Christ Roger Ebert and pumping it into
Hans and Franz uh against their will
that old saw yeah
if you've seen it once you've seen it a
thousand times okay here we go
foreign
to his senses that helping others is
more important than a career in Show
Business Arnold saves Hans and France at
the last second and the three head to
little Austria for a final showdown
exterior little Austria Town Square sang
the Havoc continues four pumped girly
men are carrying the schoolhouse
Redenbacher is now digging a huge hole
like a dog horses and townspeople are
flying everywhere suddenly Arnold
arrives in the Humvee with Hans and
fronds interior Humvee Arnold reaches
for the dashboard we see a button marked
impressive entrance he pushes it
exterior Humvee Arnold is ejected from
the cab flipping several times in a tuck
position through the air until finally
Landing feet first in the middle of the
crowd those that have witnessed this
stop in their tracks they can't believe
it's him
oh
Arnold starts pulling the Pumped up
girly men off some of the townspeople he
punches the Pumped Up Sonny Bono God
Rest his soul
wow it's sending him flying into a
clothesline where he lands in a little
more Fauntleroy outfit hanging out to
try Hans and Franz watch from the
sidelines standing near a pretty girl
now it's a Popeye episode I know yeah we
are his cousins Arnold tussles with the
pump to John Ritter and Orville
Redenbacher oh my God hey if you're
listening get out your late 80s early
90s reference card
With the Pumped up John Ritter and
Orville redenbach are seeing him flying
into twin baby carriages we stayed over
at this house Arnold punches the Pumped
up Paul Simon sending him to Skyward
he's alive Simon crashes through the
base of an Airborne plane airplane first
class same Simon's torso sticks out
through the floor a female flight
attendant approaches him care for a warm
towel sir
what a remote
oh yeah Paul Simon would do it
well if he would because of Lauren
you're right Lauren would have said you
should do it Paul it shows that you're
laughing at yourself exterior little
Austria Town Square same with the last
girlyman vanquished Arnold suddenly
notices the clock tower about to fall
over as the crowd screams in horror
Arnold begins flexing his pecs over and
over faster and faster and so they are
going so fast they tell him to float
upward like a helicopter
so
helicopter were Arnold floats
and I want you to understand this
everybody listening his pecs his pecs
are flexing so quickly they have the
same effect as helicopter blades they
create lift Arnold floats to the top of
the tower and tilts it upright as he
floats down everyone cheers Arnold he
took us shopping for clothes Franz is
still bragging to a into a girl saying
next to him Arnold climbs up on the
stage as the cheering continues all
right listen
understand what happened here this this
madness you can't wipe out curly men a
lot of these girly men are important
accountants and graphic designers are
you saying that girly men have value no
yes yes yes
I am saying it
why without girly man said be no muslim
man
who do you think made these exercise
machines curly man these machines did
not just happen turning the page
licking my finger
these machines did not just happen some
nerdy girly man sat on his sad buttocks
and designed them
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my Grandmama yeah we should say
we wanted Arnold Schwarzenegger to play
his own grandma Yeah so Arnold's wearing
a grandmother enough so we were going to
say oh and Arnold by the way we're
putting a grandmother wig on you yes
you're gonna Medea it and say
that's my Arnold Arnold is exultant he
waves to Grandma suddenly Ralph swings
from the MR little Austria banner and
knocks Arnold over gone soft Mr
Hollywood they Circle each other on
stage the crowd watches anxiously
welcome to your rap party the crowd
murmurs in approval that was a good one
sorry to be the party pooper the crowd
murmurs again that wasn't too shabby
you're the pooper I'm the pooper Scoopa
crowd murmurs loudly that was the topper
so far Ralph reaches and picks up a
large barbell scoop this we're all
flicks the barbell firing three giant
weights at Arnold Arnold catches the
first two with each hand and the third
one in his mouth he spits it out and
speaks
watch yourself I could very easily
stretch your flabs so thin I could use
it for dental floss you arrogant son of
a fritzer Roth charges Arnold with the
barbell through special effects
and trick photography I wonder why we
had to say that as if
Arnold grabs Roth and actually stretches
his buttocks and loves handles into long
ropes of flab rapidly stretching them
thinner and thinner exterior stage
moments later Arnold Thompson Franz are
sitting atop a day's draw oh my God they
are fussing their teeth with his
stretched slab
remember Fallows get under the gum it's
very important
the crowd cheers yay
suddenly lasers shoot out of the sky
narrowly missing Arnold hunts in France
they converge and form a giant swirling
holographic image that represents Mr X
postpone your celebration the
townspeople huddle in fear who's that oh
no it's the voice guy from the earlier
in the movie you have interfered and for
that you will pay the price I do not
take kindly to meddling muscle heads
fouling up my work as Mr X speaks pan
over frightened villagers faces ending
on helmet licking a candy apple suddenly
a damp t-shirt fires from the Hologram
and hovers remember this shirt front I
sent it to laundry it didn't quite make
it the T-shirt flies violently into
franz's face with a loud thwap and he
rides in disgust oh the smell
the townspeople wins helmet continues
eating suddenly 10 sweat socks shoot out
from the Hologram and hover
recognize these socks Hans I'm not sure
A Small Wonder they've been sitting at
the bottom of your laundry basket for
months the Sox fire at Hans covering him
one flies into his mouth
many of the villages are now wearing gas
masks suddenly a large jock strap fires
out of the Hologram and hovers Arnold no
no
not my Jack strap please anything but my
the jock strap shoots out and wraps
around Arnold's face craziest thing ever
the crowd screams this was your idea
the crowd screams in horror helmet still
watching him passively is jostled by a
shock villager his candy apple is stuck
to a curtain as he posed the app the
curtain is open revealing a man
operating levers Hansen Franz notice
France look over there the Hologram
effects slow down pay no attention to
the man behind the cat I don't believe
it Hans France and Arnold start moving
toward the booth the man frantically
works the controls I said pay no
attention
I the man turns weakly toward them he is
Jack LaLanne
God Rest his soul may he rest in peace
Jacqueline is a 1950s reference may
Jacqueline's children also rest in peace
laughs
oh my God we pinned the whole thing on
Jack even in 91 this was a huge stretch
it was a bit of a stretch yes yeah two
players will be reading and they say God
bless Hans in front yeah
all right all right so the Manchester
earns weekly toward them and I'll just
explain to anyone listening Jack LaLanne
was the original fitness workout guy
from the 1940s 50s 40s 50s 60s yeah yeah
I'm gonna substitute Regis for him yeah
the man turns weekly toward them he is
Jacqueline
Elaine there you go that's right it's me
you worthless hateful piece of scum
how could you well I mean I can't do it
yourself uh pick a secret word divided
talk about you okay I'm an old man
I don't have a lot going on but what
about your infomercials I knocked those
off at an hour I should have known
you're the lowest form of life on the
planet don't move a step closer dagger
now after this we'll discuss our pitch
to Jacqueline and the line you're the
lowest form of life on the planet what
would have been been an 85 year old
exercise guru I think he would have been
the first one to say yes
Elaine reaches and grabs Grandma
Schwarzenegger from the crowd he holds
it good oh the old gal gets it
you vile Little Road
I swear to God at this point Robert you
and I are just having fun
what can we say to Jacqueline who's a
revered lovely man wait till the next
line exactly
baby baby so but this rodent bikes
the lane is accepting he's up by a
little road he takes the criticism and
he puts it right back Grandma ma
expertly elbows the lane in the gut then
grabs him by his head and flips him over
her he lands on the ground with a huge
thud but Elaine gets up diving head
first into Grandma's gut Arnold moves in
to help stay back he's fine that's
grandma ma says that yeah just
distinguishing her yeah first Arnold
Arnold reluctantly backs off as grandma
and Elaine viciously go at it kicking
biting and pulling it it's an ugly
standoff until Elaine suddenly grabs
Grandma's glasses and crushes them with
Grandma disoriented the lane kicks her
in the groin
sending her to the floor arriving Arnold
samly walks over to his Humvee lifts a
side fender and pulls out a giant pump
action shotgun that's no way to treat
the lady he points the shotgun at Elaine
and fires Elaine is hit in the head
producing a giant hole that quickly
closes up via more
viomorph effect as in Terminator 2.
Elaine is made of liquid
now he says yes to the project a nice
try is watching now about my feet
gentlemen come on everybody bow
s Elaine raises his arms triumphantly in
steps aboard his Jacqueline stepper
exercise machine as the others slowly
bow at his feet he steps proudly I am
the first I am forever Hans and France
kneeling suddenly noticed a speed
control knob at the foot of the stepper
Franz quickly turns it to its top speed
the lane begins to step out of control
propels
sending him flying into the Hologram
with a loud sound the lane evaporates
into into nothing he's gone you've
killed him hail to Hans and fronds
Elaine is dead
everyone cheers
using the morph effect Bono Simon
Redenbacher instead of Happily return to
their original bodies yeah I'm turning
back into girl man as it should
and look everyone the Sun comes out
birds chirp a rainbow starts to form
the environment
it's better and still deteriorating but
you know an unacceptable rate yeah
everyone cheers suddenly near the
Horizon a large mouth forms out of the
ground it is the earth speaking
now who's gonna ask the Earth to do
still in the earth you have saved me so
that generations to come may also enjoy
my bounty I thank you all and I know
that they would thank you too
you are very welcome Earth I got you
this a bottle of wine with the ribbon on
it shoots out of the Earth's mouth and
Lance and Arnold sand
thank you aren't you going to open it
well sure okay the man at the store said
it was your favorite no no it's it's
great one
thank you thank you my pleasure well I
should be going thanks again see you
later yeah
I'm sorry one of my favorite kinds of
humor this feels very Robert to me is I
don't know it is is the dryness of the
earth opens up and thanks Arnold for
saving the environment has an awkward
conversation and then there has to be an
awkward flat conversation of I got you
this oh it's nice well the guy at the
store said it's your favorite oh no oh
yeah yeah like yeah this is a gift from
the Earth to a human and it's a bottle
of wine that Arnold's like okay with
like just put that aside I love that
Arnold is such a superstar that he has
sort of higher status than the earth yes
he does it's like the Earth is dryness
but also what the Earth what is the
earth if the Earth is a player in this
what the has it been doing this
whole movie I know now he shows up and
gives some wine I like the conversation
he has with the wine guy in the uh and
the uh you know the wine store how does
the Earth go in there yeah the Earth has
to go yeah this was before Amazon this
was before Amazon
excuse me uh yeah I'm looking for uh
something like in a red I think how much
do you want to spend uh hundreds too
much but I'd go above 50. I've just had
that flipping for what do you think
Arnold Schwarzenegger would like the
Earth asking the Earth is a reasonable
budget
that was insane I love that it's
Jacqueline I'm just thinking of all the
studio notes we would have had they
would have said the Mr X reveal cannot
be Jack LaLanne
you've got to come up with someone you
can't get the Earth it's doing another
movie now
the Earth is insulted it's a big Ebert
fan tired of making fun of himself
wow that was a great actually flossing
themselves with flowers kind of
understand why it didn't get made I
you know I don't know it was all about
Arnold if Arnold had really believed in
it and wanted but there would have been
a lot of changes probably right I don't
think this would have I think that we
would have made many concessions but you
know also it starts off so surreal and
crazy and then you wouldn't think it
could get any crazier but then all of a
sudden the Earth is talking yeah it
definitely follows a familiar pattern
which is it starts pretty insane and
then that is the low point
of insanity yeah
let's see if the Earth is the mic drop
or do we go sentimental I don't remember
it's just like a closing song I think
like one of us this is now all about the
message of learning to live yes well
everything has to have a song in it yeah
uh that's true there's a lot of many
songs but this one yes this was sort of
an obligatory kind of closing lesson
yeah okay here we go okay
exterior little Austria these Town's
been through a lot these past few days
as Arnold speaks all the principles and
townspeople gather behind him but we've
all learned something very important
yeah we learned it kaliman and muscle
men can live side by side
wait wait we talked about this Remember
[Applause]
music kicks in everyone holds hands
first Hanson Francis little garden
yeah
everyone holds hands first Hans and
franz's literal Guardian Angel sings
this is the guardian angel singing what
was the guardian angel was that earlier
in the movie that is from earlier in the
movies can you tell us what was it did
he have an accent uh it was during when
they were eating the litters of the
Hollywood sign at a low point the
guardian angel came to help and was he
just like a Clarence kind of figure yeah
exactly yeah that's what I think they
disregard yes right It's a Wonderful
Life I can eat all I want and you'll
understand I can sit on my ass and we
can live hand in hand then Paul Simon I
can get weekend fat and enjoy a KitKat
then everyone together because it's a
problem
[Music]
Gavin maccloud things I can eat mint
Milanos from Pepperidge Farms and sunny
Bono I can let my ass sag and be free of
harm I will think before I Pummel every
loser has this place I can go to the
movies and stuff my face Orville
Redenbacher I can let myself go to hell
while I work out all day that's your
grandma but I've worked out all day then
Arnold sings we cannot dubbed with James
Ingram's voice yeah we can all embody
pompitude and our own peculiar way
Guardian Angel sings I cannot have a
neck and still have a ball and the Earth
sings and if nobody litters I'm fine
with it all constant Franz it's not
pretty to look at that but we must
understand everybody
Lord of man
of man girl foreign
[Music]
what do we do now I wish I knew Amy
steps in behind them oh we'll think of
something
the three of them hug Arnold approaches
well fellas I'm on my way
my place is on the coast you guys want
to ride hunts in France both put their
arms around Amy everything we want is
right here what who's in Africa it's
like an orphan from earlier
so it's not a romantic interest no
actually oh it was it was a romantic
interest the joke was that they're so
close that they just have one girlfriend
very innocent way out of context that
looks it looks incredibly creepy yeah
it looks very strange this is just sweet
no one's having sex here yeah yeah uh
okay Hans and Franz both put their arms
around Amy and say everything we want is
right here Hans and France cheerfully
hug Arnold Arnold approaches grandma and
hugs her you know we didn't really get
to talk or even stand next to each other
but still it meant a lot to me yeah take
care leapson so we're we're now getting
mad about the fact that they're both
played by the same person yeah
he's been 30 some odd years Arnold tears
up and sadly walks away he waves goodbye
one more time then transforms into a
plane
um aerial shot of the townspeople
singing from Arnold's perspective the
Arnold plane wearing sunglasses flies
across the screen and waves to camera
the end over the credits we play a clip
of Arnold in The Pride of the Yankees
remake in which he hits a homer and
rounds the bases making an Arnold quip
to his opponent at each base
it never got made
wow that was uh that was something do it
again I can't yeah now we have the bonus
material at the time I remember even as
we were doing this thinking how would
they technically pull this off but yeah
now I I think about all the movies Lego
Movie and see and how far CGI has come
you've worked on movies like with Adam
Simpson like Don't Mess with the Zohan
yes where I know the script had things
like you know Sean chaturo tunneling
through the Earth and then you see it
and it's hilarious and it works but if
you looked at it in 1991 you might
wonder how you'd do that I guess we
thought all of these things were
physically doable with some kind of
Technology
we thought Arnold we thought Arnold
could really do them all right yeah we
were so impressed with him yeah we just
thought he could do all this stuff he
told us he told us he could do it fellas
that's what really happened he told us
yeah yeah I'll convert them to a plane
whatever you want then it's Arnold
here's the script I'm the Last Action
Hero bomb like I can't do it let me ask
you about my hands a question did any
official person read the script like
this Paramount did we get what were our
what was our feedback I think it was
Dead on Arrival because of Arnold but I
I think they hated it I I think I mean I
think I feel like Barry like the one of
the executives was like this is just
ridiculous
I think really you'd think it's
ridiculous I'll ask him because I know
I'm ridiculous you do yeah yeah he's not
going to remember no one remember this
is 30 years ago I remember that's all he
remembers I know we wrote it he wrote it
in 1991 is that right yeah but didn't we
it we reference Wayne's World in it so
I'm confused well this sketch was a cook
and I don't know if the movie was out
till 92 early we might have added that
later we must have yeah yeah to try and
get Lauren excited but I wrote a western
with Bob Odenkirk called Tucson yes and
it made the people mad that read it
they're just angry oh really yeah it was
is out there as this for sure oh I I
didn't have the same experience
I think the worst thing can happen is
just for people to read it and be bored
yeah I think the greatest Triumph is to
have a studio read it read your script
and really love it I think the second
greatest Triumph is for them to read it
and really hate it yeah because that
means you've done something it was It
was a miracle I mean Lovitz was the
sheriff and I was the guy from Ireland
who had only read about the west and was
super I come to the town and Lovitz is
up there pleading for his life when he
ran for for mayor or whatever can
there's big signs next to himself if if
I don't clean up the town you can hang
me and so he's on the news and you know
then I come to the rescue so I was you
know in Lincoln and was on a train with
a high-pitched boy it was really funny
super funny I'm sure and they hated it
which studio one guy I know probably
Columbia everything went there those
days I wrote with Odin Kirk too I wrote
a the Bears movie yeah
and it was uh similarly ridiculous it
ended with like you know the Bears
entering the Indianapolis 500 with a bus
and did good driving it
idiocy yeah and like they were so
supportive it was through Lauren and
Paramount and this executive was like oh
I want to read it please let me read it
in Bob and I it was like 160 Pages let
us cut it down we haven't I can't wait I
just have to read it and we're like fine
and we gave her the script and we never
spoke she never spoke that's
the thing they hate it they love it or
or they'll never speak to you again I'm
gonna I literally never spoke to the
woman again in my life but they always
really close nurturing and supportive
where they're going to read it we went
Robert and I went through a version of
this when we did look well with Adam
West and we were just so yeah excited
about it and we we shot it and we got
pretty much yeah we got to make we got
to make it and we got to make it the way
we wanted to make it and we were really
happy with it and we sent it to I'll
never forget we were in Bernie the
legendary Bernie brillstein's offices
and what happened was we were pretty
sure it was going to become a series I
just remember being I was very sorry you
were I was really sure that and I I was
very excited because I was young and
naive and this would be you know around
this same time as the Hans and France
movie but I remember Bernie brilstein
was telling us this thing's going to be
it's gonna be great and just then they
said oh Bernie it's NBC on the line for
you and he picked up the phone in front
of us yes and it was because they had
just had the screen he's like what's the
story and so we're excited and I'll
remember Bernie was
he picks up the phone and he's just like
so what's the good word and All City
goes like well you I think it's
hilarious what do you mean you're
treated after lunch no one wants to
laugh after lunch and immediately I saw
my future dissolve I'll never forget
that phone call either because Bernie
also you obviously represented Lauren
and the other pilot that Lauren's
company had going which was not a
brillstein co-production because Jack
Handy wasn't represented by berylstein
but you were so that's why it was a
brostein production look well was a
toonces the cat pilot yep which seems
like they'll never make that right
because it's like Jack Handy but uh as
brilliant as he was like now we're going
to put him in prime time and Rick Ludwin
over the phone Rick gladwin's telling
Bernie uh yeah I think we uh I think
toonsis is still alive and we're gonna
you're gonna take the Adam West
thing Adam is so funny in it
you're gonna kill that one you're gonna
put the cat thing on the end it's gonna
be a bomb
it's gonna tank and he's
Lauren's man he's Lord's manager he
should be saying great yeah okay some
good news yeah yeah no exaggeration that
the first time I was with Brad gray in
the office in Bernie's office on the
other side Brad Groves you want to go
say a little Bernie so we went over to
Bernie's door and just like you were all
I heard was what you got you oh you
God damn it he was like maybe we'll come
back later he had a giant he had a white
beard and white hair big guy and he was
uh iconic that's the greatest yeah just
an amazing yeah amazing incredibly
Charming absolutely and you know what I
I love birds yeah if Bernie had been
behind Hans and Franz this movie if he
had somehow he could have made it happen
he could have with sheer by just yelling
but yelling I could get a lot of
made this is folklore or true but that
Lauren maybe was or Sno maybe wasn't
going to get a pickup for 86 and it was
Bernie who went to the head of NBC You
Gotta Give the man his dignity you can't
do it like this I don't know if that's
folklore did you ever listen to his uh
audible book about his friends life what
did I do where did I go wrong all right
where did I go wrong that's really
interesting when I was over man I was
sad and my car I was listening to the
cassette tapes oh yeah I still have it
at home but it was it was really good I
liked it I mean
he's talking about living next door to
uh who was the head of Disney for a long
time Mickey Mouse yeah he lived next
door to Mickey Mouse katzenberg no no
heisner yeah yeah he said one of his
wives his Ex-Wives he was in a big
argument with her and yelling and stuff
out in the driveway and uh Eisner came
out and goes what's going on man you
guys what's what doing he goes you marry
her you marry her
all right well we got off track here
again a little Memory Lane listen a
little uh you know whatever those little
audio trims here and there yeah look at
you look at your team like a dog on the
set looks to his trainer yeah yeah I'm
looking over there yeah when I see I see
12 Angry Men no well they're angry all
right
we don't want to convict him and unless
we got evidence
Henry fonder what we did Jack LaLanne we
could certainly do Henry Fonda Vlad this
was a lot of fun I have to say I was
really looking forward to this and this
did not disappoint I forgot pretty much
all of this I did too but I remembered
it being a really fun experience I
remember that being a really great time
in my life all of us working on that and
so the chance to bring it back to life
even in this form was really enjoyable
it was great every time I go to New York
and I go buy that cable car was it the
uh Staten Island Roosevelt Roosevelt I
think that's going a little Austria that
cable car is going the last year oh
that's wasn't in the script that we read
but it was in the right yeah yeah it was
in this it's yeah that's how you get to
little Australia you get off the subway
yes
yeah yeah and that was even today when I
do stand up if I'm heckled that's always
a good go-to there's someone heckles you
yeah I look at you how's this little
girl Iman you think you know just go to
that that's the only way I do it anymore
how about you Kev do you do it I don't
do it I don't do it I move on
I do I can't picture him yeah no I don't
live in a path like that man I got too
much ahead of me you know well we've
done corporate gigs in the past uh this
is probably the 90s we would they'd
dress this up and we'd go out and do
Hans and France yeah it's sad sometimes
uh some will bring it up and I go Oh you
mean hands of friends from the 1900s I
gotcha man it's like you mean from like
30 years ago that is that what we were
going back I loved it there's nothing
wrong with that yeah you'll listen to me
and you listen good come on yeah
I know what I said before but I've
changed my mind I'm going back to Hansen
France I wonder if Kubrick ever thought
that well 2001 like I said it was like
from 25 years ago you know um
2001 but you know what I mean no you
just compared yourself to Kubrick yes my
favorite well this has been fun guys I'm
gonna wrap this up I hope you guys
enjoyed doing as much as I did I love
you guys and I say that not even making
eye contact
I know people are listening to this
they're thinking why don't they make a
movie but I mean we look the same
Arnold kind of looks older yeah but I
mean why not we pitched it as an
animated movie aren't you the guy that
won't even mention Hans and Franz in a
corporate game no I said I wouldn't do
them you wouldn't put down you'll make
the movie I'll talk about it all right
well I say I think we um I think we open
this to social media and ask for
donations uh that nothing will make
people angrier they say Kickstarter as
Arnold yeah what kickstavo it's a person
who just get it going come on and let's
do this
Kickstarter then we make a remake of the
all-time Smash Hit quality
holiday classic jingle all the way
all the way thanks everyone get down all
right guys I hope you
enjoyed this eight percent as much as we
enjoyed doing it then we uh failed
miserably all right peace out Tupac
[Music]